Hollywood movies make people worry about
the wrong things in terms of
superintelligence,
well,
we should really worry about it.
It's not malice,
but competence
where we have machines that are smarter
than us,
whose goals just aren't aligned with
ours for example.
I don't hate that.
So I don't go out of my way to stop
button and if I see one on the sidewalk,
but if I'm in charge of this
hydroelectric dam construction and just
as I'm going to flood this value of
water,
I see an ant until very no tough luck
for the ads,
right?
Their goals weren't aligned with mine
and because I'm smarter,
it's going to be my goals,
not the ants goals that get fulfilled.
We never want to put humanity and the
role of those ads.
On the other hand,
it doesn't have to be bad if you solve
the goal.
Layman problem.
My little babies tend to be in a
household surrounded by human level.
Intelligence is the smarter than the
babies and they leave their parents
right.
And that works out fine because the
goals of the parents are wonderfully
align with the goals of the child.
So the chaplain just all good.
And this is one vision that a lot of ai
researchers have.
The friendly ai vision that we will
succeed and not just making machines
that are smarter than us,
but also machines that then learn,
adopt,
then retain our goals as they get ever
smarter.
It might sound easy to get machines to
learn and adopt and retain our goals,
but these are all very tough problems.
First of all,
if you take yourself driving taxi and
tell it in the future to take you to the
airport as fast as possible and then you
get there covered in vomit and chased by
helicopters and you said,
no,
that's not what I wanted.
And it replies.
That is exactly what you asked for.
Venue have appreciated how hard it is to
get a machine to understand your goals,
your actual goals.
You know,
a human cab driver would have realized
that you also had other goals that were
unstated because she was also a human
and has all this shared reference frame.
But a machine doesn't have that unless
we explicitly teach it that.
Right.
And then once the machine understands
our goals,
there's a separate problem getting them
to re adopt the goals.
Anyone who has had kids knows how hard
or how big the difference is between
making the kids understand what you want
and actually adopt your goal to do what
you want and,
and finally,
even if you can get your kids to adopt
your goals,
that doesn't mean they're going to
retain them for life.
Right?
My kids are a lot less excited about
lego now than they were when they were
little and we don't want machines as
they ever get ever smarter to gradually
change their goals away from being
excited about protecting us and thinking
of this thing about taking care of
humanity is just a little childhood
thing like Lego is that they get bored
with.
Eventually.
If we can solve all three of these
quests,
tech challenges,
getting machines to understand our
goals,
adopt the man,
retain them,
then we can create an awesome future
because everything I love about
civilization as the product of
intelligence.
Then if we can use machines to amplify
our intelligence,
then we used to have this potential to
solve all the problems that are dumping
us today and create a better future than
we even dare to dream of.
If machines ever surpass us and can
outsmart us at all tasks,
that's going to be a really big deal
because intelligence is power.
The reason that we humans have more
power on this planet than tigers is not
because we have larger muscles are
sharper clause,
right?
It's because we're smarter than the
Tigers and in this exact same way,
it's machines are smarter than us.
It becomes perfectly plausible for them
to control us and become the rulers of
this planet and beyond.
And um,
when I j good made this famous analysis
of how you could get an intelligence
explosion,
we're intelligence just kept creating
greater and greater intelligence leaving
us far behind.
He also mentioned that this super
intelligence would be the last invention
that men need ever make.
And what he meant by that,
of course,
was it so far,
the most intelligent being on this
planet that's been doing all the
inventing,
it's been us,
but once we make machines that are
better than us at the inventing all
future technology that we ever need can
be created by those machines.
If we can make sure that they do things
for us that we want and to help us
create an awesome future where humanity
can flourish like never before.
Mm.